- On this episode we talk
about stupid questions,
integrity, and relationships
on social media.
(hip hop music)
♫ You ask questions and I answer them
♫ This is The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 109
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
India, let's get into, actually
before we get into that,
it's been really fun to
get the wonderful feedback
on social of how many
people have missed the show.
We were on a real roll
there for five or six weeks
so not having the show for an entire week
definitely built up the
demand for episode 109
so I'm as equally fired up to deliver.
The NBA finals have been phenomenal,
Staphon was super tough
on me in basketball today.
I hurt my, what's this meme
Steve that you're up to
like create a fake show
for Staphon, is that
what you're on or is it a real show?
- [Steve] That's the EP
that he's gonna be on.
- Why don't you show
Steve while he's talking.
- Staphon has an album
coming out, you ought
to follow him on Twitter
for more information.
- Steve has a reddit competitor website
coming out in three months as well.
- Let's get into the show.
- [Steve] Lick licks bro.
- Oh God, oh my God.
We have to talk about that at some point.
I mean with the fan base,
that's a lot of black
and white for you there DRock.
Alright.
- [Voiceover] Eduardo
asks, "I don't understand
"why I barely see @garyvee
in my Twitter feed
"but all over on my Facebook account."
- Eduardo, great great
statement, great question.
And the answer is because
of the attention graphs.
What I don't think people
understand is Twitter's
firehose, and this not
withstanding Chris Sacca's amazing
rant that I haven't read so
I can't even say that it's
amazing but the amazing
feedback to his amazing rant.
He's one of the great
investors of this generation,
a good friend of mine,
I'm dying to read it.
Chris, I promise, I will read it.
Probably late August
when I'm with my family.
While they're sleeping
and I'm being a good
dad but I have a chance to read.
I think Twitter's
firehose is just noisy and
I'm tweeting away and I
think I even double checked
that one to see if you were
following me and you are.
It's just busy and there's
a ton of shit going through
your stream and you're just not seeing it.
And now that I changed my profile picture
and you don't see the pink in the corner,
you're really missing
it so Facebook just has
more attention as does
Instagram which is
the best at this game,
Snapchat some level
especially since you're
holding it but using
stream terminology, the
streams, Instagram one,
Facebook two, Twitter three,
a lot will jump in and
leave comments on this episode
of no for me it's Twitter
and I get that, people
that have done a better job
keeping a small group of following down.
But as an overall big data play,
Facebook is winning that game,
it's more obvious.
I just think, even like
the UI, UX Facebook posts
are bigger, I just think
that, I think Twitter's noisy
and I think the reason
I picked this question,
cause I did forward
this one to you India,
is because the question
is the point that I'm
trying to make which is
you're noticing it more
because your noticing it more.
Think about that.
- [Voiceover] Christopher
asks, "You get questions
"all the time, some you
like, some you hate.
"Do you feel there is such
thing as a stupid question?"
- Chris, I'm not going to
go cliche here, I think that
there's probably an enormous
amount of stupid questions.
There's a lot of stupid people
with stupid points of view,
but nobody gets to be the judge
and the jury of that stupid.
What maybe stupid to me,
is not stupid to Staphon
and vice versa and so thus I
think the judge and the jury,
the person that makes the
decision whether it's stupid
is making that decision
and so I think, I think 99%
of the questions people
ask me are stupid at some
level truthfully, especially
when they're the things that
come most naturally to
me, cause people aren't
asking me questions in biophysics or
the weather or traffic theory, I mean like
actual traffic, not web traffic.
People don't ask me a
lot of questions about
things that I'm not
knowledgable in so I think
all of us when we have
a depth of knowledge
of something can think
things are stupid because
we know them well and others don't.
Stupids an ugly word by the
way, I hate that God damn word.
The energy of the question
is there's a human
that decides if it's
stupid or not and I think
the politically correct
answer to this question
is no, you learn from it
or in all that and I'm
into being PC, I think,
you know I'm sure
some of the homies
here thought I would go
that route with this
answer but not India but
DRock maybe,
he get's tricked sometimes.
And so that's that guys, yes
there are stupid questions.
This question's (beep) amazing, go ahead.
[Voiceover] Ryan asks, "My
bro's been dating a girl for
"two years and she still
refuses to acknowledge their
"relationship on social media, red flag?"
- Ryan, your brother is in deep (beep).
Any relationship that
is two years old where
one of the people in
the relationship has not
acknowledged it publically
on a social network
platform is up to some scandalous (beep).
Period, end of story. There's nothing
else to being said there.
I don't want to hear that you like to
keep it private, on the DL, scandalous.
(laughter)
(chatting in background)
- Tommy Lasorda, let's do it.
- This is Tommy Lasorda.
Gary I want to ask you
how do you keep your people motivated?
- Tommy, thanks for the great question.
Obviously, being one of the
great managers of all time
this answer's gonna come
very easy to you and
very natural, I think you'll get it.
I spend a lot of time
thinking about motivation
and I think the key for me is I try
to motivate in a couple of ways.
Number one by example,
I think my actions will
always speak louder than my words so how I
carry myself, how I interact
with everybody, how I
live my life as a man I
think really matters as an
executive, as a person, I think
everyone's always watching.
But I also think I equally
try to reverse engineer every
single individual person, right.
They're just all different,
they all have different KPIs,
different objectives,
they're in different parts of
their lives, some are married
some just had kids, some are
trying to make more
money, some don't want to
have four roommates in
Brooklyn, so they're grinding.
So everybody's got a
different thing and I think
what's important for me to
motivate is to do a great
job listening to what makes
them tick, both when I
have the few moments with them in person.
Alex, get over here for a second.
Let's do a real life example
on the #AskGaryVee Show.
Alex, what motivates you,
what are you excited about?
- What am I excited about? In life?
- Yeah, what motivates you in life?
- I just like doing cool
(beep), that's it pretty much.
I want to be successful
and just do cool (beep),
that's basically why I'm here so you know.
- Cool man, alright, get out of here.
So, Alex is easy, he just
wants to do cool (beep).
So that's easy, we do tons of cool (beep).
He's check, he's good, he's motivated.
And you go on and on and on and you
try to figure out, was he
scared that he was on camera
and is that the real
answer, like are they really
gonna tell me the truth,
they never tell me the truth
usually upfront, few and
far between and so it's
a constant behavioral HR driven reverse
engineering what they care about.
India and I had a pretty
intense conversation
about her future ambitions,
remember you wanted
to be the head of social
media for museums.
I take that very seriously,
like I know these things
about my peeps, this is
even before India was on
the inner circle of this team, like I
I remembered it
better than you did.
- Yeah, that's true, you did it's true.
- So I take enormous,
you don't get to be a great
all time leader without being
a great all time leader.
There's a lot of work that
gets put into being good
at what I do and I'm very,
very up to the challenge
and so it's predicated on an
enormous amount of listening
which is why I'm such a
paradox because boy do I (beep)
love to talk but the amount
of listening that I'm actually
doing always surprises
people when they start going
a couple of layers deeper so
the answer to your question
is I motivate, Tommy, by
figuring out what every
single person is ticked and wired like and
what makes them roll and I also recognize
that that changes every
single day and they
have four to seven, twelve
milestone things that
happen in their lives,
which will change the
trajectory of their
ambitions, wants, hopes,
and dreams and I need to be prepared for
every single one of those
for all of them forever.
- [Voiceover] Dylan asks "Do you
still believe that there's
"integrity in the
communications industry?"
- Dylan I want to too
and I think the answer is
there absolutely is but I
think that there's integrity,
there's very little integrity
in every single market,
advertising, politics, sports, music.
The reason integrity is so
attractive is it's so hard.
It's far and few between and
integrity's defined differently
by everybody and I think
it's interesting to watch.
I actually think society
is giving people more
room to be flawed, which is intriguing.
I think the level of
integrity, the way integrity is
viewed upon today I
think is in a much better
place than it was by society
let's say 50 years ago
because I think we're
now factoring in that
nobody's perfect and we're making mistakes
even by standards like
drugs and relationships
and cheating, like intense
stuff, I think there's
an interesting evolution and I think that
that's allowed for a
little bit more gray and
a little bit more if you're
really on your high horse
creating a scenario where
you judge integrity.
But I think in a lot of ways
there's plenty of integrity.
I think there's a ton of
integrity out there still.
I've been saying this
a lot lately, I said on
another video, are we gonna bang out that
video that I did earlier today?
- [Voiceover] Which one, we did four.
- Yeah I know, the last one we did.
- [Voiceover] The Twitter one?
- Yeah, Staphon's working on it?
- [Voiceover] Yup.
- In there I say, no I think
it was a different one.
- [Voiceover] It was the other one.
- It was in another one, I screwed up.
But, I'm a big fan of this
thing that's on my mind
right now which is you find
what you're looking for.
You know, I see integrity everyday.
Everyday and I think it's
because I look for it
and I look half glass full,
like this is Niagra Falls to me.
Like this is a very full
glass and I think that plenty
of people can see plenty
of what's missing.
I think that's as much on you my man as it
is on what's actually
happening in the marketplace.
This is a good episode,
I feel good about myself.
Went deep, 109 was a deep episode.
Just show them DeMayo just
for kicks and giggles.
Let's go, the camera will, let's find him.
DeMayo, the camera will find you.
Don't try to hide.
- What's up everybody.
- DeMayo, you get to ask
the question of the day.
- Oh boy, what are you going
to get AJ for his wedding?
- You're asking the
entire VaynerNation?
- No, I'm asking you.
- No, this is not me, you
messed up the question.
- Oh, alright.
- You know, we're keeping that.
What are you getting AJ for
his wedding this weekend?
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(laughter)
- [Matt] Yo.
- Yo.
- [Matt] Are you going to
do calls tomorrow on the road?
- I'm willing to.
Give me an hour to get, yeah speak to Liz.
I want the kids set, give
me some breathing room.
But I'll take like an
hour in there, you know.
(hip hop music)